hi my name is Ahmad watch out now from
South Sudan I'm excited to be here the
World Economic Forum and also as a
matter a young global leader I'm a
recording artist and also I do a lot of
social so comment like a social
entrepreneur so the question that I'm
trying to answer now is will the
greatest challenge to the region be
environmental economic or social yeah
they are going to be the challenge all
these things affect each other the
reason is a social problem is because of
poverty level are high and as well as
the environment is going to be affected
people are not going to take a challenge
in five environment like for example in
20 and 40 they'll be less fish in the
ocean which means that will affect
economy to they'll be less cool so if we
don't take our environment it will
affect our social our life so the crime
and the quality are gonna rise so
economy is affected when people r plus 1
and as people are spending more to buy
stuff to buy or to buy clothing that's
when the economy is able to grow so all
these things affect each other so we
have to put in a big fight take care of
the environment and other things are
going to work better peace